we need to clarify that it wasn't the
las vegas thunder
that he played for it was the las vegas
thunder from down under
just to clarify all right 78 degrees our
official high for the day today one
degree shy of that record
tomorrow look at that 71 look at that
temperature drop for tomorrow and it's
going to get even cooler as we get into
the weekend
and into next week 72 centi hills right
now somewhere in 68 73 for aliante
77 sunrise mountains 78 for green valley
double
i should say 75 for rhodes ranch and
mountains edge 75
also for henderson outside of town 72
for pump
love you guys out there over the hump 73
in boulder city got a lot of viewers out
there 2 and 84
in laflin we've got a lot of viewers all
over southern nevada
and over in arizona too thank you so
much doppler radar staying dry
clouds overhead right now great
lenticular clouds over the mountains
those will dissipate soon wind cast
shows that those winds will decrease
tonight
they won't be a big issue tomorrow we'll
have some north breezes still around
but i think saturday we'll see those
north breezes kick up again but they
will not be anywhere near what we saw
today today was the peak wind gusts and
we've been telling you about that
since the last week we'll be they'll
give you the heads up temperature trend
now here's the numbers okay look at here
here are the numbers high 60s sunday
monday we're only in the mid 60s and
we're right near average this is where
we should be okay
now the day before thanksgiving
pre-thanksgiving we're looking at
mid-60s so we're not looking huge
warm up and i really don't see a lot of
wind happening for next week too so if
you're going out for that morning jog
remember still be it'll be a little
chilly in the morning we'll have a
little bit of light breeze still left
over so we'll call it fair for the
morning for that morning jog brian's a
big jogger
now big time so this is your this is
your slow
this is how about slow you go see how
slow that is that's brian right there
good no for the rest of the day so great
day for some exercise for tomorrow 51
degrees in the morning chilly 67 by
lunchtime
71 in the afternoon like we said cooler
tomorrow than today's 78 degree high
here's your
ted said seven day forecast north breeze
is on saturday
and like we talked about temperatures
will be nice and cool but keep in mind
it will be chilly also into next week as
well
plenty of sunshine as we head into
thanksgiving
maybe kirsten gives another gobble
gobble but if not
we'll send it back over to you